[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 195 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mark and I'm here with my colleague and
new host Priyanka hey Priyanka hi how
are you doing I am super excited to be
part of Google cloud toss cause from now
on absolutely and I know you have been
not just a host but also a guest on an
episode previously but now you'll be
joining us as a host as well yes it's
super awesome and of course in our
interview today you and I got a chance
to sit down with Kathy and Jessica about
some best practices for conversation AI
they're both Googlers here and they kind
of work on different teams but it's
really cool to hear the different
perspectives on what's important and how
do you design good conversation systems
yeah and the more exciting part is
Jessica brings the developer perspective
and then Kathy brings her conversational
design experience from over the years of
building IVRS and then moving into
building conversational designs so I'm
super excited for them to be here so
it's a lot of fun but we also have a
cool question of the week I saw that you
put out a blog post about how do you
integrate dialogue flow and bigquery
those are two very different tools yeah
yeah so we're gonna be getting into what
that looks like a little bit later but
before we do that let's talk about our
cool things of the week
[Applause]
yeah so I had something cool I read this
blog post that promised Korean himself
had published out on Google and Mayo
Clinic's new revolutionary partnership
in terms of AI in healthcare and it's
really exciting to see how we are able
to take the AI innovations that we do at
Google and apply them to some of the
practical applications like the patient
experience clinical experience and then
diagnostic and even research so there's
going to be some more stuff as a part of
this partnership coming up which will be
a combination of the security and the
compliance that Google Cloud offers in
the platform combining with the
infrastructure so check out the blog
post but in general it seems to be a
very exciting venture where we're going
to explore possibilities in healthcare
with the Google cloud platform yeah it's
always super cool to hear about
different companies that are using GCP
but I think a lot of it like you
mentioned is really based on what the
technologies are enabling them to do and
then kind of all the cool research and
future potential that comes out of that
yeah pretty exciting super super cool
well I actually have two cool things of
the week the first one is some really
really big memory optimized virtual
machines and when I say big I mean big
because apparently and this is news
these are six and twelve terabyte memory
virtual machines Wow which just blows my
mind in every possible way because I
remember the day of trying to get my
hands on like 256 Meg chips putting them
into an old desktop computer probably
cutting myself on the ram one too many
times so to think about the scale of how
it's changed from back in the day all
the way to these 12 terabytes of memory
I mean it's astonishing
yeah the blog post is talking a little
bit about how these are certified for SA
P Hana and using it for those types of
workloads but I guess you can probably
just use them for any other application
that might need 12 terabytes of memory
to run
yeah this is some cool exciting yourself
that's the kind of stuff that I think
that when customers come up and they see
oh look you know we have these hideous
technology or these tools available
that's when they can say well we're
really good at our subject matter what
can we do with these new tools what can
we find out things and just like Mayo
Clinic I think there's some cool
opportunities there yep
what was your second cool thing of the
week my second cool thing of the week is
a great little educational hands-on lab
actually it's a quest so it's a full set
of videos and labs and then a little
quiz at the end all called understanding
your GCP costs so I've been working on
this for a while I've talked about it in
a couple of the previous podcast
episodes and you can also see these
videos on the Google cloud platform
YouTube channel but it's kind of a good
starting place to look at understanding
your GCP costs right I mean it's
incredibly important to understand what
tools are available for you to measure
your costs and then starting with this
quest and then the you know the next
content that I'll be coming out it gives
you a little bit more hands-on guidance
for how to actually control your costs
so things you can put into place there's
a bunch of different discount tools like
sustains use discounts committed use
discounts but then also like identifying
resources that you're not using and then
putting budgets and quotas into place so
you can control it it's actually really
super cool because when you think about
it I think a lot of people just kind of
you know use the cloud they use the
machines they go for it and then they're
like okay well pay X amount well as you
get to be a big business that doesn't
make as much sense you know you need to
plant you need control your cost
effectively so this is a really cool way
to start with that and I wanted to tease
out that there is a code I don't know
how long it'll last for so you know if
it doesn't work ping me or something
we'll figure something out but there's a
code 1q - costs six to six so I'm sure
that I'll be in the description of the
show notes but if you use that you can
get the labs part for free so quick labs
I think normally has credits that you
need to do the labs and this will let
you bypass that you know I really really
recommend it for people - especially
people who are in finance to get a
better grasp on what the cost controls
are but I think this is introductory
level enough that everyone maybe should
look at getting a baseline understanding
of where those costs are coming from and
how to analyze them so that they can
kind of tackle the cloud a lot more
responsibly
do you also
a little bit about maybe like how do I
set up my organizations so the costs are
properly limited and stuff in that video
series that you talked about earlier
absolutely so there's a video or two on
a resource hierarchy and organizations
and again these are things that you know
the average individual user someone
who's not either using it as part of a
business or as part of a small business
may not run into but especially for
large businesses and enterprises and so
forth the organization is a very very
important part of how you structure your
Google cloud platform resources and
learning about that can be really really
handy for scaling out yeah I remember
those questions coming up a lot with
enterprise customers that I spoke with
so I think it's amazing to have that
resource and we'll make sure that the
link for the videos go in the
description absolutely well with all
that cool stuff out of the way let's get
right into our interview with Kathy and
Jessica
[Music]
Kathy Jessica thanks so much for joining
us today first things first tell us who
you are and what you do yeah so I am
head of conversation design outreach
here at Google and basically that means
I talk a lot about conversation design
what it is and try to bring awareness so
thank you so much I'm a developer
advocate for actions on Google which
means I could have built a lot of voice
applications and through that I build a
lot of content from the learnings that I
get so we could teach other third-party
developers how to build for Google
assistant and then with that I also get
all the feedback from developers on what
goes great and what goes not so great
and bring that bar so the product teams
we can make it better
gotcha so first things first Kathy what
is conversation design right you
mentioned that you kind of focus on that
I don't know what that is that is an
excellent question that I'm asked many
times basically you can think of it as
we are trying to teach computers to
communicate like humans and not the
other way around so basically rather
than have you learned some complex way
of either speaking or typing or tapping
or swiping we'd rather leverage how
humans have been speaking for what
150,000 years and make it that much
easier to get things done get the
information you need just the way you're
naturally used to doing and so we want
to work in the world where we're
thinking about how humans communicate
and then applying that within the
technical constraints that exist today
so I have a question about that so I
think we we got the definition of how to
work with conversation design but
Jessica I have this question for you is
this any different than how we interact
with maybe say apps or websites and do
developers have to do something specific
when they develop for voice no
definitely developing for voice is very
different than something with a GUI
because there's all control as a
developer when you have a GUI there's
only so many buttons a user could push
first is a conversation at any point
someone could say anything and you're
supposed to support the user through
that and it's not just necessarily that
they could see anything at any time
because most people would have learned
from Kathy they're cooperative they want
to support you and be able to talk
through things we're not going to be
just bringing something crazy into the
conversation it's more on how people
explain things or
communicate could be slightly different
and our voice applications are actions
that we call them in Google assistant we
call those actions and sub apps we have
to figure out how to capture those
different types of utterances that users
can say and give them the appropriate
response so it's definitely a different
mental shift when it comes to thinking
about how you built and something that
I've seen and I actually experienced
what I read my first application once I
built it and as I was going to the docs
its head design I was like that's cool
I'll do that later because as a web
developer that's what I would do I would
kind of built all the scaffolding
then I'd bring in all the design after
and it turns out no can't do that this
time you have to have the conversation
design first and then you build after so
are there like a list of best practices
are there a bunch of like design Doc's
on how to do conversation design yeah we
actually have established a lot of best
practices and principles and can go to
for example actions google.com slash
design get a whole ton of information of
even what is it how to get started the
first thing we always recommend to
people whether you're a developer or
marketer or whoever whatever role you
have is to start with something called
sample dialogues and what that means is
basically you're creating a conversation
it's like a movie script it's a back and
forth between the user and the action
and that just really helps you sort out
the complexities of what this is gonna
look like cuz a lot of times like
Jessica mentioned people think oh yeah
the words will just fix those later but
in fact the words are the structure and
it's gonna impact the flow and the
wording and everything throughout your
whole development cycle so you might as
well start with design in the beginning
and really save yourself a lot of
headaches so can anyone write these
conversation design practices or when we
start to develop is it just the
developer who are the stakeholders
involved when somebody is thinking about
designing something like a conversation
I think in the ideal world a team will
have a conversation designer as part of
it and that person can really help steer
the direction of how things should sound
what things we need to keep in mind what
are we gonna need from the back end all
that kind of stuff now I understand in
the real world not everybody's gonna
have a conversation designer to work
with so instead in those cases I
definitely encourage the developer or
the project manager whoever it is to
really study
on best practices and then write sample
dialogues and then what you do is just
like in Hollywood with a movie script
you do a table read you read them out
loud because sometimes we write formally
and when we actually hear those things
out loud they sound kind of stiff and
awkward so you really want to read out
loud with other people and you'll
quickly get a feel for where things are
going well and where things are going
wrong and that can really help anybody
really get started and do a better job
yeah I think the last time we chatted
with Priyanka a little bit about some of
the other chat options specifically
built into Google we kind of brought up
the idea of people being frustrated by
being very locked into kind of an older
school version of a voice system where
it wants you to say something very
exactly I like right yeah I want one
small cup of coffee that is dark brew
please and it adds a lot more effort
into it as opposed to how people might
more naturally speak you know you
mentioned earlier Jessica that you
thought about the code part of it first
and the design part of it later and that
can you know lead to a lot of challenges
using these best practices how do you
kind of convince somebody like to
actually take them into account and
actually spend the time upfront working
with them before just kind of trotting
off and doing the code part
oh yeah that's something that I've
constantly seen whenever I go out
especially when I do like a one day
workshop it's really unrealistic to have
a great design a great voice application
built in one day it takes a long time
and so I definitely try to do my little
soapbox speech of like oh my gosh I
spent hours thinking these they're
technical issues when I was building
prior to having a design it turns out
was a design issue I didn't know where I
was going in regards to the conversation
flow so I think that's kind of my mantra
I'm constantly trying to figure out I
don't think I have it great kind of
convincing argument besides sharing my
story and sharing kind of the statistics
on like it takes more time and you're
gonna end up spending more developer
time in the long run trying to fix those
mistakes and because voice is still
fairly new I think it's more people are
gonna be experiencing that and then they
realize and they go oh Jessica and Kathy
they were right so is there an example
you can share of where someone might
have run into that or example that
you've run into specifically yeah my
very very first voice application that I
built point of the application was to
mock or mimic technical interviews
because the hard part when it comes to
interview
it's not so much being able to solve the
technical problems it's hearing the
problems I'm practicing it and hear it
from someone else so they cool I'll
build this thing and it's a really cool
tool I would have loved to have had this
when I was going through my process of
looking for a job and I would get into
these weird kind of scuffles where I
would start but how would I bring the
user from giving them that information
bringing them back and laying them how
to come back and I knew how to do that
technically but when I sent it out and
had people try it out it wasn't natural
what it felt weird don't think well how
can I be clever and like putting little
flags and try to bring them back and
it's like oh my gosh why am i doing all
this overhead to solve our problem where
I could have just stopped and went okay
let me talk to other people let me
figure out and build the actual
conversation design by using sample
dialogues anything something that could
be really challenging or something that
I know when I mentioned to folks
specially developers those are sample
dialogues I get the for what is that
it's like home it's literally writing
down pretend you're the action and
pretend someone else is the user and
having that conversation so I usually
like telling people just grab two
friends tell one of their friends you
are the action this is what you do use
you know the other friend you are the
user no talk and just let them naturally
talk and write that down and how they're
doing it is the best free way to do that
yeah no I'm just to give you a really
basic example I think a lot about yes/no
questions and how often we we fail the
user on those because a lot of times
people will say well I ask them yes/no
questions so let's say I asked you do
you like candy and you might say yes you
said yes I do like candy you didn't say
yes I just broke the chat pod you
shouldn't have broken it if somebody
design it well or I might even say like
well do you count chocolate which is
neither a yes or a no but it's a very
natural thing for someone to say and so
someone who's really thinking things
through and following best practices is
not just going to be like oh I told them
to say yes or no that's all I'm gonna
accept they're gonna say what are
related things they might say or maybe
you're booking a table at a restaurant
and you say how many people in your
party and maybe I say well do outdoor
seating now that's a related question
but it's not a number like you asked me
for it that being said I'm not gonna
suddenly say how tall is Barack Obama
when you asked me you know how many
people in your party so it's what we
call sort of adjacent topics so you
might not answer the exact
but the user will say something related
and you need to anticipate those or
things are gonna fail very quickly yeah
I think this is something Priyanka you
brought up the last time we chatted
about people don't know exactly how to
have a conversation yeah I think which
is first of all a fascinating subject I
mean just you're mentioning earlier if
you tell two people to have a
conversation
boy they get really awkward really
quickly think about everything you say
but people don't normally think about
everything they say they just kind of
keep talking and eventually their brain
might catch up but for people like me no
words are way faster than thought so you
can just keep on talking but it's an
interesting thing because when you
actually call it out I don't think a lot
of people do think about like how much
we use especially contextually right
which is one of the hardest things to
grab but one of the most important
pieces of a conversation because you can
ask a question like exactly that we know
India about door seating it's like oh
well you're talking about this
restaurant you're talking about this how
do you handle that kind of idea that
people don't know how to have a
conversation yeah I think it goes back
to the point where you don't just start
coding right you start to think about
how it's going to have interaction with
not just one person but different people
right because I could talk about things
in a different way and I think we talked
about this last time when we were like
if I want coffee depending on the time
of the day and the day and the
frustration amount I would ask for
coffee in different ways like when I'm
happy to be like wow coffee this is
amazing oh my gosh can I just get coffee
right now I'm so frustrated like things
like that
I think we have to incorporate how a
user could react in different situations
and ask for the same thing in different
ways and then I guess people coming from
different places with different accents
could ask for certain things in
different ways so things like that but
Kathy I would like to ask you what are
the things that are hard to deal with
when we are working with conversation I
think one of the things that's difficult
and Jessica was talking about the
difference between something like a GUI
versus a Bui as we call it voice user
interface is the fact that with a GUI
you know what they did they pressed a
button they swipe they chose a menu item
with voice and natural language
understanding it's a little bit more of
an educated guess
you know speech recognition act
has improved dramatically and the time
I've been working in this field but it's
not perfect and human speech we don't
get it right all the time either but
when humans have a misunderstanding we
are really good at what we call
conversational repair if you say
something like I went to the
such-and-such restaurant last night I
didn't hear that I'd say what restaurant
and you'd say oh this one and we'd move
on and we're very good at that kind of
repair and that's something you really
have to anticipate when you're
developing these conversations which is
no matter how good your design is no
matter how good your prompts are people
are gonna say things that you did not
expect and you will get an error and you
need to spend actual time thinking
through what is my strategy for handling
when things go off the rails how do I
get somebody back on track and just
doing the default of like sorry I didn't
understand please say that again he's
terrible it won't work and but did we
see it all the time it's a great way to
get your blood pressure up real quick
and so we really think more like what's
the user doing what do we just ask them
let's rephrase the question a bit oh we
have another error okay let's give them
more information maybe they can't find
their account number and we need to tell
them more
you have to know up front you're gonna
spend time on error handling or repair
and that is going to be the
make-it-or-break-it difference between
your users having a successful
experience or not yeah I was kind of
mentioned earlier that sometimes people
will say something completely unrelated
to what you know you were asking about
is that handled in the same way do you
try to handle it in a like context
shifting way and you say now we're
talking about this so the AI is just has
to keep up or do you try to keep them in
line with what the original conversation
was it kind of depends on the goal it's
like if you're trying to book a table
then you do want to get them through
those questions but you should be
flexible you don't have to answer the
questions in the exact same order on the
other hand if they're saying something
completely out of context you may not be
able to help but another thing I want to
mention is basically if somebody says
something that you can't do
acknowledgement is really important so
for example if I go to a concierge at a
hotel and I say hey can you rent a car
for me and let's say they can't let's
say they only do dinner reservations if
the person just said I don't understand
do you want dinner reservations I know I
want to run a car what the human will
actually say is I'm sorry I can't rent a
car would you like dinner reservations
so our systems if you look in the logs
and a lot of people are requesting a
feature that you do not have don't just
say I don't understand you should do
this other thing say oh sorry
we don't do that feature yet I can do
this or that people like to be
acknowledged when you have a frustrating
day and you're talking about it with
somebody you don't want them to say well
I don't know it I'll help you you want
them to say wow I hear you're saying
that you had a difficult talk with your
coworker people want to be acknowledged
and this is true even for a voice user
interface so it's incredibly important
to make sure that the conversation
system is very clear about what it can
and can't handle but also that it still
tries to keep users down that path while
matching all of the kind of requests of
that I mean I'm assuming this is kind of
covered in those best practices of
things to keep in mind when you're
designing a system yeah for sure
like you said you want to further them
towards the goal but at the same time
keeping them from having a frustrating
experience and sort of gently guiding
them back on track yeah most third-party
voice applications don't do everything
they don't necessarily it shouldn't
replicate the Google assistant because
Google system could do all the things
generally a lot of what developers are
bill T are specific to a niche or to a
certain topic and so that's where I know
I felt several applications and there
are times where users are not as
knowledgeable that I can't tell a joke
because that's not what the actions
about but most likely the user is
thinking that they're talking to Google
assisted and so I have an intent instead
of all my actions going hey you might be
one cool assistant just say goodbye and
I'll get you out and when you want to
chat about X say hey Google talk to blah
and that way it could get the user to
what they want to do and it's not for
seeing me as a developer trying to solve
all the problems because that's not the
purpose of individual actions yeah and
so what are some of the common pitfalls
that developers actually come across in
their trying to develop I think we
talked a little bit with Kathy about how
do you actually like repair conversation
with the conversation design aspect of
it but we didn't touch a little bit on
the developer aspects and what do they
see as challenges I would say the
biggest challenge is not choosing the
rice use case doing things through voice
is great but it's not helpful when
you're searching for something
particular and there's lots of options
on your train a narrow it down it might
be helpful to narrow it down using voice
but then maybe at the end the user might
want to be able to see the last three
options because they
want to get into the details and that's
where you could use multimodal I'm
having a smart display or being able to
show that other smart phone might be a
helpful set up instead of just appending
all envoys because that might not be
necessary the best use case for that and
so I think the best use case and I
usually tell folks if it's something
you're already doing with your voice
that's a great thing to make into an
action if it's something like you're
using let's say spreadsheets that might
be a little more challenging to go okay
if I want to get column four and row B
and trying to figure that out if your
spreadsheet is lerton you have like
actual like labels on things and it
could make sense then that would make a
lot more sense you brought up a great
point there about multi-modality and
with new devices out there we are
getting into that world so Kathy would
you mind touching a little bit on how do
you design properly for those multimodal
devices and you know just for anyone who
may not be sure what multimodal means
you know definition would be fantastic
for me but you know so muslin modal were
generally referring to the case where
there are different ways you can
interact with the technology so for
example Jessica mentioned smart displays
like the Google home hub so that is what
we call a voice for word device so you
can do a lot of things with your voice
but there is the addition of a screen
and so you can see things like if you're
shopping for a blue shirt you can see
the pictures on there and something like
a phone of course is also multimodal
because you can type you can speak you
can tap you can swipe so when we're
thinking about designing for these new
surfaces its kind of exciting because
something like the smart display it's
very new and we haven't quite all
figured out exactly with all the best
use cases are yet but generally our
guidelines are that when you are
thinking about this the first thing you
need to understand is that although it
would be great unfortunately you can't
just design once and be done for all
surfaces obviously there are things that
are in common across all of them there
will be some differences as well so our
advice is to start with the voice first
experience like the smart speaker
because believe it or not that is often
the most complex or maybe most
constrained case and if you get the
conversation done right or the smart
speaker then what you do is you go to
something like the smart display and you
say okay now we have the option for
visual elements where would it benefit
the conversation to add visual
components at this point and then you
can do the same for the phone as well
so start with the voice only experience
and expand from there a lot of times
people go with oh we're gonna have the
pretty pictures first and then they get
back to smart speaking they're like I
don't know what to do so definitely
start with voice what also adds like a
tremendous level of complexity when
you're talking about mixing and matching
all these different interface not only
is it now you're doing conversation
design you're also doing all the actual
interface design and then I have to
imagine it's exponential in terms of
difficulty because you're trying to mix
them and there's enough eighties sci-fi
shows out there that kind of showed
people interacting with computers and
then talking to the computers and maybe
even using some kind of third-party tool
all of these things mixing together to
kind of create one single experience
that's gonna be hell for UI designers
whether its graphical visual or a
combination what does that look like
right now it's a significant challenge
and I think it's important to to
acknowledge that and if you are for
example running a business or you're the
person who's the decision maker about
we're gonna do this conversation action
you just have to keep in mind that it's
gonna take some time and you have to
have these different skill sets so you
have to have a visual designer you have
to have these different folks who are
gonna work together and we have
established some of these nice processes
where there's handoffs and so we really
are establishing these best practices to
deal with these new multimodal services
because as you say it does add
complexity when you've got to be
thinking about all these things but
again if you go through the process in
the right order you'll save yourself a
lot of headaches and hassles and they'll
be a little smoother definitely and I
would say even just building a voice
conversation application it's not where
you could just work in the silo all by
yourself it's really working with the
different parties and working together
so I definitely think meeting with the
voice first building that experience
first lays out a lot of great groundwork
and then adding in the visuals the
compliments the support and even the
visuals we do have a new tool called
canvas where you can bring in HTML CSS
and JavaScript into play which is a
totally completely new experience and
you could play games and do lots of fun
interactive simulations too you really
make the experience more rich but
definitely want to start with voice and
then you can add in those fun features
later but I want to bring up chemists
kids either with canvas you don't
necessarily
generally have it set up where there's
buttons because it's a surface you could
just use your voice and so you don't
need like a green button to go you just
say go and just kind of make that more
part of the visual elements and so an
example would be lets say you have a
game where there's a little character
instead of pushing buttons that's his
attack or like go home or XYZ just push
on like the monster you want to attack
and push on the home icon thing like in
the background so you could go and do it
that way and set or of course use your
voice to control your character so it's
a different type of UI experience as
well so if you were to pinpoint some of
the use cases for the listeners today
what would be some of the best use cases
to kind of handle or tackle as the
beginners who are starting to think
about creating something for voice yeah
I mean as Jessica mentioned one of the
one of the good indicators is do you
have conversations with other humans
about this thing because that's often a
good indicator also of course the
context where is the person are they in
the kitchen and their hands are busy or
they're a new parent and they're always
holding their babies so they don't have
use of their hands or they're in the car
and you really need to reduce the
cognitive load but you really have to
ask yourself what is better about
someone doing this task through
something like a smart speaker than on
an app you know maybe it's not and I
think a lot of companies get excited
like we're gonna build your voice is
gonna be awesome and then it fails and
like I don't understand why didn't it
work as well because it's faster for me
to do it you know on my phone so you
need to think through some of these
things like what's the value add truly
for doing something on a smart speaker
the other thing I was going to say is
that a wonderful place to be thinking
about conversation design is really
through the idea of inclusive design
which is we want to make sure that
whatever your product or feature is or
the information you have available can
everyone access it and voice technology
is really reaching the point finally
where it's getting mature enough to help
really the people who need it the most
may be somebody who is visually impaired
somebody who has muscular dystrophy and
can't use their hands to do things but
they can use their voice and that's
really one of the places I think right
now voice is is the most powerful but to
me this idea of inclusive design isn't
just about this one group or that one
group it's it's really about all of us
because all of us throughout our lives
have situational impairments where maybe
you're walking in the door and you're
holding your groceries and you briefly
don't have you
your hands or I can't find my reading
glasses and I can't read this important
text message or I broke my arm all of
these things so really it's about
building for everybody and do I need to
be a machine learning expert and do I
need to know natural language processing
in order to start building for voice no
which is fantastic I know when I first
started in this field I was really
intimidated and scared that I would have
to learn all these really interesting
concepts and really challenging concepts
and the time to get up to speed on that
would take a while and what's great is
we provided tool called dialogue flow
that does the MOU for you and so what's
great is that you just as a developer
identify the different intents or
functionalities that the user could
potentially have within your voice
application and just provide training
phrases to specify for each of those
possible interactions and it handles the
machine learning for you so what's
really great is you don't need to do
that but if you're interested in that
you can also connect Google assistant to
your own and oh you as well so you don't
have to use that well so if you do have
that background and that knowledge great
connected to any other I know you that
you have but if you don't don't worry
about it so it sounds like there's a
bunch of cool tools out there people
want to get started including dialog
flow and of course Priyanka you've got
the deconstructing chat bot series that
goes into a little bit of this and links
out to a bunch of other useful resources
yeah we also have a bunch of code labs
to refer to while you do the
deconstructing chat pod videos so if
people are really interested in that
that sounds like a good starting point
if people want to learn more about the
best practices you mentioned the link
earlier
are there other good resources for those
best practices or for thinking about
conversation design we've also got some
videos out there on things like
conversation repair also persona we
didn't really touch on that but when you
are designing you want to be thinking
about the personality and the
characteristics of your action or your
conversational experience so personas
and other important things so we have
some videos resources for that as well
so what's in the future for a
conversation design because I saw this
little thing about alter ego there's
some pretty interesting prototyping work
going on right now alter ego is one
example which is out of MIT Media Lab
and it's all around the idea of a lot of
us might be comfortable talking to our
smart speakers in our own home but maybe
not when we're on
busts are out about on the street or
even in our office it could be a little
annoying hear everybody talking to their
computer so there's this idea of silent
speech or subvocalization which sounds
very sci-fi where essentially you are
wearing something along your jaw line
and what it's doing is it's picking up
pre speech signals so as you start to
form words before the words actually
come out of your mouth you're doing
these tiny little signals that are
actually indicating what it is that
you're about to speak and so this
technology is picking up on those pre
speech signals and translating them
silently into words which could then be
passed along to a voice assistant and of
course the responses could be done in
your headphones so no one would actually
hear it and I encourage people to look
at the alter ego video that MIT Media
Lab put out to check it out so that's
like an example of someone taking this
conversation design and just short
cutting the actual meaning to talk part
well you're still talking it's just that
the words are not audible which to me is
what I would define talking as but
speaking maybe I should are conversing I
don't know what the right verb is but
you're still having a conversation but
you can think of it just like when
you're typing to somebody you're talking
to somebody but the words are not spoken
out loud so I mean it could open up a
lot of avenues it sounds like for almost
like an additional interface to
communicate with these things but I'm
guessing it would still follow a lot of
the same conversation best practices and
guys for sure and even if you're talking
to say a chat bot that's typing only
you're still following the same best
practices and when you type to a chat
bot it's much more like spoken words
than it is like if you're writing a
formal essay or something like that so
even though it's a different modality
you're still following conversational
principles and what about for cool tools
coming up or any other you know future
products that are really cool for people
to check out yeah we recently just
announced canvas and that's like the
cool new thing right now where again
you're bringing in web technologies into
voice and making that voice forward so
that is really exciting and I believe
that just God noun says for GA this
month so that's like hot off the presses
the nearest thing right now awesome well
I guess we did talk a little bit about
who you are and what you do initially
but if people want to find you what
would you like to share where you're
going to be in the next few days or your
Twitter handles so I am
Perle 42 on twitter i also log on medium
from time to time and i'll be speaking
in january at project voice and what is
project voice project voice is going to
get together a whole lot of voice
developer and designer and biz dev folks
too for a week of talking about all
things voice and conversation how to
build the products use cases everybody
together to really talk through those
things you can definitely follow me on
twitter my handle is chat the sweetie
all one word and i also blog a lot of
medium as well so you definitely check
that out on the Google developers medium
page right now I'm really seeing season
two of assistant on air which is a video
series where we have conversations with
folks who build for google assistants so
season 1 was all about talking to
Googlers internally how they build and
why they build Google assistant or
actions on Google in that particular way
or how they could use the tools and
season she was all about our gdes
which are Google developer experts so
there are folks globally around the
world who are experts within building
for Google assistant and I sit down and
chat with them awesome well thank you
all so much for coming in I think we had
some really cool understanding more I
mean I definitely walked in here without
knowing what conversation design was and
now I know a slightly bit more so thank
you all for coming in thanks very much
awesome thanks happiness
thanks so much to Kathy and Jessica for
coming in and talking about like I said
before the best practice is around
conversation AI I really like that note
you said Priyanka about how it's a good
balance between the design of
conversation AI and the experience there
but also the development aspect of it
and how do you combine those two to make
a good system yeah it was very
enlightening to hear not just from the
Google assistant perspective but the
general aspect of designing any
experience from the conversational point
of view and speaking of which I think
it's about time to get into our question
of the week
for this you published a blog post I
wanted to ask you more about it
you have a solution here to combine
dialogue flow and bigquery and I mean my
first question of course is why would
you do that what tools are available in
there that make that useful but then
also how do you do it so when I've been
speaking with customers and users of
dialogue flow one of the cool questions
that always comes up is I want to take
some of the data that I'm getting from
the users like I take an example of an
appointment schedule and the time and
the date and why people want to set an
appointment for coming to whatever it is
that I serve as a service right and I
just wrote this cool little tool to
understand there is the reporting side
of things that dialogue flow offers but
there's always an analysis that you may
want to do as a business in terms of
what you want to make decisions offer so
I take these appointment things from the
users date time and why they want to
come in and then I want to do my own
analysis to understand when do people
come in more or what are the different
requests that I'm getting more versus
this and all of that is very easily
available as where it was and I can pass
them into bigquery and I can run sequel
commands on it so it's a very good way
to find out how can I provide a better
customer experience and what are some of
the questions I should even automate or
not automate is an indication that you
can get with an integration like this so
that's the why aspect of why I came to
think that this could be a good tool and
how do you do it is actually pretty
simple in dialogue flow you have the
fulfillment where you can write no js'
code to make a connection to any API so
in this case I'm using the bigquery API
to take those variables that I'm
capturing as a part of dialogue flow the
dates and the times and why people want
to come in for this appointment and then
just pass those variables into a table
by calling my bigquery API from the
cloud function that is inside
fulfillment from dialogue flow so it's
pretty simple integration if you want to
look at a sample or want to do it
yourself I have
linked some of the code into github and
you can download that from the
repository as well so like you still get
to use the dialogue aspect of dialogue
flow in creating the chat bot but then
you're easily able to take a question
that somebody asks or some information
that somebody provides and then
basically query against bigquery which
is really good at well big queries and
then take that get an answer back and
then use that back in your dialogue flow
application you could either use that
back in your dialogue through
application or you could take that
information and create your business
strategy off of it and be like okay now
I should change my bot or I should add
you know these questions because people
are asking for these more that type of
stuff so you can decide where to focus
more of your energy on but as you said
you can also process it and send the
response back to the dialogue flow to
have further conversation so both ways
yeah would you recommend that people
generally take the conversations that
users are having with their dialogue
flow apps and record all that
information in bigquery so they can make
decisions it is a good practice to do
that if they are thinking about you know
mln AI aspects of taking this huge
amount of data and making sense of it
and then utilizing it to either better
improve the conversational experience or
to provide more experiences that they
may not be thinking of providing today
just based on what the users are asking
for super cool so we've got that article
down there and it sounds like the codes
on github as well yeah so it'll be a
great opportunity for people to actually
pretty easily try it out yeah awesome
well I think we're just about out of
time but before we go Priyanka do you
have any cool fun trips coming up any
big events yeah I have a lot of travel
coming up in October I will be in Europe
OB and go to Berlin doing a talk on
natural language processing and
conversational AI and then similar in
Milan and then later in November I'll be
and Copenhagen doing NLP and
conversational AI talks again oh that's
a lot of travel coming up for you yeah
and then after that I am going to be on
me
in December so I'm looking forward to
that it sounds like you might need it
maybe a staycation would be better
exactly yeah with family Shh yeah I
think I'll have a vacation coming up as
well so definitely looking forward to
unplugged for a little bit and you know
maybe maybe I won't even bring my laptop
with me I've been juggling that idea
we'll see if it actually happens or not
but you should definitely try to do that
because without laptop life can be good
well thanks everyone so much for tuning
in whether you're tuning in from your
phone or from your laptop
hopefully life can still be good while
listening to a podcast so we'll see you
all next week
[Music]
I can't even find my window sorry too
many tabs too many tabs somehow the
world has gotten into a scenario we're
having a hundred and fifty tabs open is
acceptable I know I don't get it I don't
understand how people stay organized as
so many tabs open